in ukraine the un's nuclear agency says
a safety zone must immediately be set up
at a nuclear power plant to prevent a
disaster inspectors who visited the
plant say its security is being
undermined by constant shelling and
russian military equipment on the site
the plant remains cut off from ukraine's
electric grid large areas of ukraine
have been left without any power sources
amid all the fighting debra patta is in
european ukraine near kiev deborah it's
a disturbing development good morning
indeed good morning this was one of the
worst hit places by russian forces just
look at these buildings these are
people's homes and despite the
devastation many residents actually
still live here as they have nowhere
else to go
winter is coming an ominous icy threat
i'm terrified says larissa dubrova
she remembers the bone chilling cold of
february when russia declared war on
ukrainian civilians aiming their
missiles on her neighborhood
after that my life was divided into
performed after she recalls trapped
inside her home as russian forces seized
european with temperatures plummeting
almost below zero
it was a kind of freezing that blinds
you you can't even think even my flowers
were frozen
in towns like this across the country
volunteers are helping repair shattered
buildings so that people who have
nowhere else to live can at least go
home for winter you still don't have gas
you have no heating and you can't cook
what are you going to do
i don't know she says gulping back sobs
it's a fear shared by europe where an
energy crisis could lead to rolling
blackouts shuttered factories and a deep
recession
russia has choked off supplies from the
north stream one pipeline that supplied
40 percent of this continent's gas
cynically the kremlin says it had no
choice blaming sanctions as global
prices saw
ukraine is worried that it's energy
blackmail aimed at dividing its western
allies and their support of them against
russia's invasion
gas isn't our weapon
it seems so i hope western leaders are
wise enough to make the right decisions
she says
because we are all hostages of this war
dubuva empathizes with westerners facing
rising energy bills but points out that
compared to ukraine
could be a lot worse tony
debra patter forest once again in
ukraine deborah thank you very much